ce nicolas vidal nicolas quel regard est
ce que vous portez sur cette
mobilisation parisienne
oui bonjour ce fils qui m'en bat on peut
noter déjà effectivement que il ya une
impossibilité de la part de la
préfecture de police de paris
d'interdire la manifestation puisque les
gens manifestement se sont regroupés
alors je sais pas combien ils sont
exactement sur quel secteur et ce en mai
après bon il ya ce premier point
ensuite après bombay ça peut poser aussi
des questions effectivement des
interactions manifester et cela pose des
questions de philosophie politique vous
savez libertés fondamentales et puis
troisième élément de réponse rapidement
sophie je voulais dire comme je le pense
la question qui se pose dans cette
manifestation dans ces manifestations de
soutien au peuple palestinien
c'est l'importation du conflit étrangers
sur notre sol moi c'est ça qui me pose
en question la question de fond qui est
dessous c'est ça il est assez récurrent
en france mais l'a finalement en l'état
français que peut-il aujourd'hui sur ce
conflit israélo palestinien si la
question qui se pose ça fait plusieurs
années que beaucoup de puissances
s'affrontent arrive pas bien entendu à
régler ce problème donc si je me pose
tous la question moi de cette
importation des cons qui vous voyez ce
qui pour une fois je suis d'accord
une fois n'est pas coutume je suis
d'accord des guerriers natale voilà moi
ce qui m'inquiète c'est l'importation de
conflits sur notre sol et je crois qu'on
a beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes à
régler et très sincèrement voilà voilà
comment je cadre on peut cette question
là on va pas et pas inévitable justement
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas inévitable
importations de de ce conflit en france
ben le problème c'est que j'ai envie de
vous répondre
moi je pose des théories des hypothèses
je suis un éditorialiste mais on dirait
qu'à une libanisation aujourd'hui notre
société de notre communauté nationale
et c'est là nous avons des gens
effectivement qu'ils viennent manifester
pour des causes qui sont souvent très
éloignées pour certaines de la france et
sur le théâtre d'opérations mais pour
d'autres c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
nous sommes qu'elle confie dray le
palestinien je le répète encore ça fait
des années des décennies que ce problème
se pose entre israël et les palestiniens
est aujourd'hui qu'est ce que peut faire
la france dans ce conflit là ça ne tient
pas qu'à emmanuel macron donc c'est pour
ça que moi je m'inquiète toujours il ya
encore plus maintenant sophie encore
plus maintenant parce que moi cette
libanisation de notre pays de notre
unité nationale de l'allégeance et la
communauté nationale finalement elle
prend de plus en plus d'ampleur et c'est
assez inquiétant ces manifestations en
l'occurrence celle ci est ce que vous
vous portez sur l'apostolat france sur
les récentes déclarations d' emmanuel
macron oui mais moi ce que je regarde
surtout j'ai un regard on va dire sur le
long terme je parle de décénnie
bien entendu aujourd'hui comment elle
est le levier diplomatique pour pouvoir
un moment donné essayer de régler ces
problèmes le confient les complexes
sincèrement et je vous le dis je suis
allé à quelques mois de ça un résident
rails notamment même de gaza jusqu à
kerem shalom et je me suis rendu compte
chekpoint qui était vraiment au sud
d'israël entre le sinaï l'egypte la
bande de gaza et israël
et on se rend compte une fois sur place
que c'est extrêmement complexe donc la
place de la france ce n'est pas que la
place de la france ce n'est pas que le
levier que doit activer la france c'est
la communauté nationale qui dans son
mensonge qui dans son ensemble se casser
dans son second fils a d'ailleurs on se
rend compte aussi que la palestine a
perdu des années notamment ont salué
avec l'égypte l'arabie saoudite donc de
cesser des plaques tectoniques
géostratégique géopolitique très
complexe et il très sincèrement
aujourd'hui le sens de l'arrêt de la
location 6 une manifestation de soutien
pourquoi pas mais aujourd'hui donc le
problème très très complexe et je lui
redis je vous le redis pour moi c'est
manifestement une importation d'un cours
qui très éloignées sur notre sol et je
crois que la france a déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes pour ne pas même
porté d'autre est de mettre de l'huile
sur le feu doux doux quelques seul
canton soir voilà c'est aussi l'europe
qui doit se positionner sur le conflit
au proche orient aujourd'hui vie si vous
aviez une diplomatie européenne sophie
si vous aviez une diplomatie européenne
je vous encourage je vous renvoie au
rendez-vous d'ursula von der leyen et de
charles michel à ankara en turquie
devant recep erdogan
mais il faudrait que l'union européenne
est et pour sa diplomatie
et pour avoir une diplomatie vous savez
que c'est le propre de lempire
finalement qu'à des vassaux d'aider sa
façon et je crois pas aujourd'hui que
l'union européenne est une diplomatie
une vision claire nette et globale et
massive de ces problèmes là donc
ça posera toujours en sous main on va me
le dire encore que je par l'union
européenne mais plus que vous me posez
la question je réponds et bon plaisir
mais ça peut croire le problème de la
force politique que représente l'union
européenne et aujourd'hui je crois que
sur les théâtres d'opérations ils sont
la diplomatie la france avait encore il
ya quelques temps vous savez une voix
qui porte et et je crois que c'est de
moins en moins le cas donc ça pose une
question pour ça vraiment très la très
très large triglobal est alors sur la
manifestation parisienne qui a donc été
interdite par le ministère de
l'intérieur par la préfecture de police
de paris
est-ce que c'était la bonne stratégie
visiblement elle n'a pas empêché les
protestataires à se rassembler cet après
midi je vous le disais nous dit c'est
faire dans le sujet une présentation
4300 forces de l'ap de nos policiers qui
sont allés sur le terrain mais on
entendu associé au brave m notamment et
bien effectivement les organisateurs ils
ont défié la préfecture de police de
paris
là dessus donc ça c'est toujours c'est
toujours compliqué pour pour un état
pour une préfecture finalement d'être
désavoué sur une interdiction
on l'a dit aussi c'était pas si devant
le tribunal ni ce trafic qui a aussi dit
la médiation soit interdite
donc là on est vraiment finalement les
organisateurs en quelque sorte ont défié
la préfecture de police de paris et j'ai
trouvé la clavicule plus de paris
souvent bien moins sympathique avec
certaines manies les gens du début voyez
vous une certaine autorité
mené après elle donne carrément
interdites il ya rien qui s'est passé
donc s'impose aussi toutes ces questions
et je le disais tout à l'heure ça pose
aussi des questions libertés
fondamentales de manifester de
revendiquer et donc c'est vraiment
problème très large et et ces
manifestations il faut les voir avec un
peu de hauteur de vue me semble type
pour essayer de comprendre mais très
sincèrement le problème reste entier et
vous direz que les tensions étaient
inévitables on a vu ces affrontements
entre les manifestants cet après midi et
les forces de l'ordre alors ça sur
pareil je vends le propre des
manifestations qui deviennent plus en
plus violente on le voit aux fugues et
samedi le foie pour tout près tous les
manifestations vous avez des
groupuscules qui sont à une
manifestation on espère toujours bien
entendu que un maximum manifestants
viennent là paisiblement pour manifester
sur un an un intervenant le dit
nos reportages micro-trottoir bien
entendu mais vous avez toujours de plus
en plus des groupuscules qui se met dans
les manifestations et qui viennent créer
le trouble qui viennent semer le trouble
qui sent extrêmement violent qui sont là
pour le défaut de l'ordre public et ça
c'est de plus en plus compliqué ces
moments de plus en plus conquis team
mais c'est toujours pareil la
composition de manifestations alors
cette manifestation a été maintenue par
les organisateurs une trentaine
d'associations qui ont malgré
l'interdiction appelait à se rassembler
on les a très peu vu finalement sur les
images ses organisateurs ben oui me
semble-t-il alors j'ai pas fait tous les
jets passer tous les images de plusieurs
prêts midi mais finalement oui le
dimanche vous montrer notamment sur arte
france oui on est on y voit très peu
mais une nouvelle fois sa poste voilà
c'est moi cette panique à sion me pose
vraiment la question pose vraiment la
question essentielle de l'importation en
confie la tuer je crois qu'à un moment
donné
la france aujourd'hui n'a pas besoin on
n'a pas besoin de mettre de l'huile sur
le feu dans ce pays qui est déjà
extrêmement fracturée et moi ça me pose
la question de la libanisation aussi de
ce pays-là des communautés qui
manifestent pour des coups aux fiches
des déchets nucléaires mais c'est ça
pour moi qui me qui m'inquiète
énormément voilà sept libanisation de la
france qui est en train de fracturer
petit à petit pour ça et pour d'autres
choses bien entendu on l'a vu ces
dernières semaines avec des riches avec
l'élève des généraux les veines des
militaires n'active maintenant la lettre
d'un ancien policier
on voit bien que tout ça un espèce de
fil rouge qui est de plus en plus
inquiétants et ce fil rouge est en train
d'être tendu tendu tendue est ce qu'un
jour il va pas casser
très sincèrement je ne l'espère pas